[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 14 juin voici les
titres de ce journal c'est la journée
mondiale des donneurs de sang à cette
occasion le fs lance de nouveau sa
campagne prenait le relais un mois pour
tous donnés afin de passer l'été sans
trop de difficultés interview du
directeur régional de l'es2 le ffs et
puis reportage à toussus-le-noble un
nouveau lieu de collecte a ouvert ses
portes et dans un mois tout juste c'est
le 14 juillet la fête nationale et son
traditionnel défilé se prépare aussi
dans les yvelines pour la partie
aérienne les pilotes se sont réunis à la
base 100 cède 2 vélizy villacoublay
invite également de cette édition jean
charles g slow maître de conférences en
histoire contemporaine à l'université
versailles saint quentin
enfin c'est en 2023 que devrait avoir
lieu la première édition du festival
pulsations à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
elle avait été remporté l an passé en
raison du contexte sanitaire en
attendant anima sauce a mis en place des
rencontres avec les partenaires
objectif maintenir le lien jusqu'au
festival mais avant de développer ses
titres cinq en cinq ans quasiment jour
pour jour qui a été perpétré l'attentât
de magnanville le 13 juin 2016 un couple
de policiers jessica schneider et jean
parti jean baptiste salvin était
assassinat et au domicile familial une
attaque au couteau par un individu
radicaliser sous les yeux de leur fils
de trois ans le terroriste avait été
abattu ensuite par les forces de l'ordre
ce lundi matin gérald darmanin s'est
rendu au commissariat des mureaux le
ministre de l'intérieur a participé à
une cérémonie suivie d'un dépôt de gerbe
dans la cour du commissariat ce
commissariat où officiaient jean
baptiste salvin dans son discours gérald
darmanin affirmé que la nation devait
admiration reconnaissance et protection
à ses policiers
[Musique]
ce lundi 14 aux gens c'est donc la
journée mondiale des donneurs de sang un
événement pour connaître à l'échelle
internationale les besoins en produits
sanguins est sensibilisé à ce geste
essentiel alors que les réserves
atteignent un seuil inquiétant à
toussus-le-noble la motivation de
bénévoles et de la commune a permis
d'ouvrir un nouveau lieu de collecte et
mélanie poquet eléonore si nos quais et
bérangère bourgoin 100% tous eu les
donneurs défilent ce vendredi 11 juin
les 90 créneaux proposés ont vite trouvé
preneur le point commun des volontaires
ils sont pour la plupart des habitants
de toussus le noble
je suis à quelques minutes donc c'est
facile de s'y rendre vu que c'est plus
proche
je pense que les personnes de tous ceux
qui habitent ici ça incitera plus de
personnes à venir directement à côté de
chez eux
il ya eu quand même beaucoup
d'informations données à travers les
réseaux sociaux et les messageries
whatsapp donc automatiquement c'est plus
facile au départ de la mobilisation ivo
jeunesse de l'association cent pour sang
tous eu ce nobel tu soient obtenues
rapidement le soutien de la mairie pour
mettre à disposition l'espace culturel
du plessis le rôle de la section 100%
tous uc2 de fédérer les collectes enfin
de communiquer entre le l'établissement
français du sang et l'amérique tout su
nous à titre de bénévoles va d'organiser
comme on le peut l'ouverture de la porte
de la salle l'accueil des participants
dans la remise des bouteilles d'eau fin
de l année là les conduire la campagne
d'affichage de boîtes âge ça a été
extrêmement rapide j'ai eu une première
demande il ya un mois de notre
association 100% tout su et la semaine
suivante le fs était déjà ici sur place
avec nos services techniques pour
visiter les lieux pour voir s'ils
étaient adaptés à leurs besoins et
effectivement c'était le cas donc en une
semaine nous avons pu organiser cette
première collecte
la prochaine collecte est d'ores et déjà
prévu les équipes de bénévoles et de le
fs donne rendez vous aux volontaires le
16 septembre prochain
l'établissement français du sang a
annoncé vouloir faire de
toussus-le-noble la collecte de
référence sur le secteur
l'établissement français du sang relance
d'ailleurs jusqu'au 9 juillet prenait le
relais un mois pour tous donné
objectif faire remonter les stocks de
sang particulièrement bas ce mois ci est
les précisions de stéphane noël
directeur régional de le fs au micro de
célia gars de son gant et l'objectif
c'est de mobiliser la population
francilienne pour donner son sang et
quand je parle de la population
francilienne je parle naturellement des
donneurs qui est déjà nous voir et qu'il
ne rencontre a réuni rançon de collecte
mais je parle également des personnes
qui n'ont pas encore osé franchir le cap
et qui n'ont pas encore eu le réflexe de
venir nous rejoindre sur une colle est
la période estivale est une période qui
est difficile dans la mesure où des
produits sanguins fléchissent pas la
demande en produits sanguins ne fléchit
pas les patients vous savez ils prennent
pas de vacances
les patients tous les joueurs ont besoin
d'être pris en charge ils sont encore
prises important cette année dans une
seconde nous constatons actuellement que
la demande en produits sanguins d'une
très élevé elle est très élevée tout
simplement parce que après la période
kovy douillet beaucoup de
déprogrammation actuellement les
services hospitaliers tourne à plat
voire même tome de manière plus
importante qu'en temps normal
et de fait la demande en produits
sanguins est extrêmement importante et
nous devons collectivement y faire face
il ya de très nombreuses collectes qui
se déroule actuellement en ile de france
vous voulez retrouver tous nos lieux de
collecte sur notre application autour du
sang sur notre site internet
et pour donner son sang c'est très
facile vous allez sur notre site
internet vous trouverez la collecte la
plus proche de chez vous vous pourrez
prendre rendez vous sur ce même sujet
j'ajoute que les députés ont adopté
mercredi 9 juin un amendement de la loi
bioéthique sur le don du sang
il vise à supprimer la période
d'abstinence de quatre mois que devaient
respecter les personnes homosexuelles
pour rappel le don du sang n'est ouvert
que depuis 2010 9 aux hommes ayant eu
des relations avec d'autres hommes avec
sous réserves jusque là donc de cette
période d'abstinence
spectacles ateliers rencontres
témoignages au programme de la nuit du
handicap 2021 événement national qui
s'est déclinée aussi au niveau local
s'est tenue samedi dans les jardins de
la mairie de versailles
le but une soirée festive et conviviale
pour faciliter les rencontres entre
personnes en situation de handicap et
celles qui ne le sont pas faire évoluer
aussi le regard sur le handicap et créer
du lien durable
le rendez-vous a été un succès a
rassemblé plusieurs centaines de
personnes
rendez vous l'année prochaine est la
fête nationale du 14 juillet c'est dans
pile un mois les pilotes chef de bloc du
défilé aérien se sont réunis pendant une
journée en fin de semaine dernière à la
base aérienne 116 de vélizy-villacoublay
autour du commandant du défilé aérien
ils poursuivent les préparatifs pour le
jour j avec comme thématique cette année
est de gagner l'avenir nicolas landry
était sur place il a lieu chaque année
mais se prépare bien en amont de manière
minutieuse et rigoureuse
le défilé aérien du 14 juillet rassemble
91 appareils hélicoptères avions
chasseurs différents aéronefs de l'armée
de l'air de la marine nationale de la
gendarmerie ou encore de la sécurité
civile avec une organisation
particulière
le défilé qui est constitué d'un
ensemble de patrouille qui vont attendre
dans l'ouest parisien
qu'on leur donne le top départ est bien
se rejoignent petit à petit sur un axe
qui est la kz2 des films et c'est bien
par le respect des altitudes le respect
des vitesses le respect des trajectoires
le respect des horaires
le respect des procédures radio que la
sécurité aérienne est garanti pour cette
journée à la base aérienne 107 de
vélizy-villacoublay tous les pilotes
chef de bloc sont réunis c'est le cas du
sous-lieutenant aurélien navigateur au
sein d'un awacs
un avion de l'armée de l'air doté d'un
radar charge à chacun dans son avion et
dans son son équipe d'avion leader +
équipiers de préparer la mission au
mieux en traçant des cartes en préparant
visualisant sa mission avant et ensuite
pour être au rendez vous répétition
générale et le 14 juillet à l'heure sur
les points le navigateur en charge tout
ce qui va être la gestion de la
trajectoire avec les pilotes ainsi que
le timing sur chaque point de notre
trajectoire
donc on est là vraiment pour assister
les pilotes et que puisse se concentrer
exclusivement à la mène la
manoeuvrabilité de l'avion
[Musique]
après le briefing du matin les pilotes
ont pu faire des repérages aborde
différents hélicoptères des points
d'identification de la défense à la
place de la concorde pour faciliter le
défilé pilote d'un mirage 2000d le
commandant nicolas sera suivi de cinq
mirage 2000d et de six rafale les
premiers repères qu'on essaie
d'identifier sont des repères avec des
développements verticaux qui nous
permettront en cas de mauvaise météo de
pouvoir nous affranchir de d'une
visibilité médiocre ou faibles donc
jusqu'à 5km de visibilité horizontale
pour pouvoir nous aligner sur la défense
et ensuite être axé parfaitement une
répétition générale du défilé aérien
doit avoir lieu fin juin dans le loiret
et pour parler du 14 juillet avec nous
en visioconférence justement jean
charles g slow bon soir
bonsoir mais vous êtes maître de
conférences en histoire contemporaine à
l'université versailles saint quentin
avec vous on va revenir sur les origines
de ce 14 juillet aussi quel héritage les
styles aujourd'hui et déjà rétablies
sont une vérité jean charles g selon le
14 juillet on ne commémore pas la prise
de la bastille comme le voudraient
l'imaginaire collectif mais plutôt la
fête de la fédération qui a eu lieu elle
le 14 juillet 1790 ça alors pour être
juste on commémore pas seulement le 14e
les 89 fonds on commémore en fait les
deux puisque lorient s'est agit de
définir une date en effet début la
troisième république
il ya eu beaucoup de débats et le 14
juillet a évoqué un peu trop la violence
de la prise de la bastille pour les
opposants à la république et on a
préféré donc en effet mettre l'accent
sur la fête de la fédération de cette
grande fête qui avait réuni pour
l'anniversaire le premier anniversaire
de la prise de la bastille des
représentants de tous les deux boucles
et les régions de france où c'était
l'unité la nation retrouver mais on n'a
pas oublié malgré tout le 14 juillet 89
qui au delà de la violence de
l'événement est la conquête de la
liberté donc à une symbolique qui que
l'on retrouve encore aujourd'hui dans la
célébration du 14 juillet donc c'est
donc c'est les deux que se passe-t-il
justement ce jour de la fête de la
fédération
que s'est-il passé le 14 juillet 1790 du
coup
une grande cérémonie révolutionnaire a
été organisée au champ-de-mars à paris
qui n'avait pas encore évidemment de
tour eiffel à son bassin de côté et donc
lors d'une grande messe à la fois
religieuse et patriotique
on a célébré l'union retrouvée de la
nation autour de son voie de façon à
gommer un peu les affrontements parfois
violents qui avaient eu lieu depuis les
débuts de la révolution
et pourquoi votre avis dans l'imaginaire
collectif on a oublié justement cette
date de la fête de la fédération au
détriment de celle du 14 juillet 1789
avec cette date symbolique de la prise
de la bastille pourquoi à votre avis
dans dans l'imaginaire collectif on
pense d'abord au 14 juillet 1789
parce que c'est un c'est un événement
qui a été a été justement fondateur en
quelque sorte de la révolution la
révolution populaire parce que jusque-là
le la révolution était plutôt celle des
états généraux donc des représentants de
la bourgeoisie on va dire pour faire
simple et donc cet événement qui plus
est violent qui marque les esprits a
davantage été retenue dans l'imaginaire
collectif que la fête de la fédération
alors par la suite le 14 juillet a été
célébrée parfois aussi interdite cette
cette fête n'est finalement qu'en 1880
celle-ci juillet 1881 très précisément
qu'elle est devenue officiellement la
fête nationale tout à fait c'est le 6
juillet 1180 kg et voter une loi qui
instaure ou réinstaure le 14 juillet
comme fête nationale puisque entre la
révolution et sept années 1880 il y eu
plusieurs régimes qui se sont succédé
des empires des monarchies qui ont qui
ont interdit la célébration du 14
juillet comme symbole de la de la
république et qui ont mis en avant
d'autres dates pour célébrer la fête
nationale sous les empires c'est le 15
août
quel est le jour anniversaire de la
naissance de napoléon alors que sous la
monarchie par exemple ça va être soit
louis xviii le jour de la saint louis ou
souchard le disent le jour de la saint
charles
voilà donc c'est il faut attendre 1880
et le retour au pouvoir des républicains
pour que le 14 juillet devienne la fête
nationale et qu'elle est encore jeune
qu'il est on remonte le temps avec des
fêtes nationales qui ont été plus
célèbre que d'autres notamment pour les
100 ans justement de la fête de la lys
en temps la fédération pardon de cette
journée de la célébration de la
fédération en 1890 aussi après la
première et la seconde guerre mondiale
avec ça intéressant si le souligner une
forme qui peut évoluer et notamment une
fête nationale qui s'adapte à son temps
peut citer des exemples très récent 2015
avec le raid et le gign et labeyrie qui
ont défilé après l'attentât de charlie
hebdo et l'an passé aussi
cette journée a été dédiée aux soignants
avec avec cette crise sanitaire donc
finalement elle s'adapte aussi à son
temps cette fête nationale
tout à fait il ya une volonté de faire
évoluer cette cette cérémonie qui est
alors qui est qui est installé dans un
certain rituel qu'on a l'habitude de
retrouver chaque année vous avez évoqué
le défilé militaire le survol de des
champs elysées par par la patrouille de
france
il y à des ventes et donc de faire
évoluer de s'ouvrir peut-être à la
société civile puisque
traditionnellement le grand événement du
14 juillet c'est le défilé militaire à
paris mais voilà où la lah ouvert aux
astuces l'année dernière c'était un peu
particulier puisque en contexte de
pandémie
le défilé n'a pas vraiment eu lieu
c'était plutôt un hommage au défunt
notamment aux personnels soignants
largement impliqués dans la gestion de
la crise épidémique mais on peut citer
auparavant l'ouverture d'autres qui
d'ouverture par exemple en 2007 le
président nicolas sarkozy avait ouvert à
l'europe puisque les des soldats
européens avaient participé au défilé
alors que des dignitaires européens
étaient également présents invités
officiels à cette cérémonie
donc c'est une fête qui qui essaie
d'évoluer en même temps que la société
même si elle a du mal peut-être à à
trouver un souffle un peu nouveau dans
une société qui connaît une crise
notamment en matière sociale ou
identitaire alors qu'elle a
traditionnellement un rôle justement
d'union entre les français et le
enjeu est encore plus important depuis
quelques années d'ailleurs ce
traditionnel défilé qui passe bien sûr
par les champs elysées ça c'est une
tradition depuis 1981 auparavant s'était
déjà passé par les champs-elysées mais
il y avait des défis qui pouvait passer
aussi ailleurs alors plus de 200 ans
après même si elle a peut-être perdu on
va dire de sa signification de deux
basés à l'impression quand même que les
français sont attachés à cette fête
nationale quand les défilés étaient
encore autorisés
hors période que vit bien sûr on voit
que ça rassemble beaucoup de monde
notamment ceux se défiler sur les
champs-elysées il ya il ya un côté aussi
d'attachement des français pour cette
fête nationale oui sûrement il ya sarah
sans beaucoup de monde mais ça n'a
jamais rassemblé tout le monde sait ça
en fait l'enjeu c'est que depuis les
débuts du 14 juillet il ya toujours une
frange en plus ou moins important de la
population qui a refusé d'y participer
parenti républicanisme par exemple l'or
lors des premières années lorsque la
république était encore fragile
donc oui ça rassemble beaucoup de monde
oui il ya sûrement un attachement des
français le 14 juillet mais à quoi sont
ils attaché dans ce 14 juillet est ce
que c'est à la célébration des valeurs
de la république
est-ce que c'était la célébration de la
grandeur de la nation est ce que c'était
la célébration du pouvoir en place qu'il
se met en scène quand même de façon très
importante de durant cet événement ou
est-ce que c'est tout simplement
l'attachement à ce jour férié ce jour de
fête où se retrouvent
on va voir le feu d'artifice où on va au
bal des pompiers etc etc
il faut voir quelles sont les raisons de
cette cette affection des français pour
le 14 juillet une dernière question
faudrait-il plus de pédagogie peut être
dès le plus jeune âge pourrait expliquer
justement ce qui est à la base le 14
juillet est ce que votre avis ça peut
être bien aussi de faire un peu plus de
pédagogie
la pédagogie elle est faite je pense que
ce soit à l'école primaire où ensuite
dans au collège ou au lycée on apprend
les symboles de la république et
notamment le 14 juillet donc peut-être
faire de la pédagogie pour les adultes
qu'on peut être eu tendance à oublier la
signification profonde de l'événement
après avoir quitté l'école
mais oui il n'est jamais mauvais de
faire de la pédagogie de toute façon
finalement que l'héritage est toujours
présent même si les significations on
peut être évoluer autour de ce 14
juillet merci jean charles g slow
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
maître de conférences à lui vécu
l'université versailles saint quentin en
histoire contemporaine dans l'actualité
également l'épidémie de kovy 19 qui
confirme son recul dans les yvelines et
indicateurs sur une semaine sont tous à
la baisse dans le département et
diminution pour le taux d'incidence est
le taux de positivité respectivement -
39,2 et moins 1,1 point depuis le 6 juin
la tension hospitalière aussi est en
diminution 53,6 % des lits de
réanimation sont actuellement occupées
en ile de france 223 patient était
toujours hospitalisé hier dimanche sur
le territoire soixante sept de moins
qu'il ya une semaine et depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire 1828 personnes
sont mortes ducobu 19 dans les hôpitaux
du département
au chapitre politique les élections
départementales et régionales c'est dans
six jours premier tour ce dimanche les
candidats ont donc encore quelques jours
pour faire campagne et jeudi derniers
ensembles pour les ivy la majorité
sortante au conseil départemental tenait
un meeting c'était au forum
armand peugeot en présence des binômes
investi dans les 21 cantons et aussi de
gérard larcher président du sénat
face à eux pays y pour les
départementales dans le département des
yvelines la république en marche aligné
cinq candidats cinq binômes candidats
dans cinq cantons le rassemblement
national est également présents des
candidatures indépendantes également
enfin la gauche partira elle en ordre
dispersé avec des alliances sur quelques
territoires seulement six projets
d'envergure pour l'enseignement
supérieur accompagner dans les yvelines
jeudi dernier le conseil départemental a
acté cet investissement est de 207
millions d'euros pour une part une
signature est les précisions dans ce
sujet de bixente mais rien senti steban
le département a signé un financement
pour six projets destinés à
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche et
la formation médicale et scientifique
l'investissement le plus important celui
du rassemblement des centres de
recherche d'evry et palaiseau de l'école
des mines à versailles-satory ce
déménagement va nous permettre à la fois
de rejoindre 1
bâtiment très moderne et très sobre mais
surtout de rejoindre un écosystème
d'innovation à côté de partenaires
industriels deux partenaires académiques
très très de très grande notoriété et
également de lieu d'accueil et de
développement de start-up un
investissement estimé à 98 millions
d'euros montant global du projet 275
millions d'euros
pour l'instant le département assure
trois quarts du financement
il va de soi que si nous n'arrivions pas
à convaincre nos partenaires du contrat
de plan état région
participer à ce financement ce que nous
trouverions j'utilise un mot peut être
fort mais je le pense
scandaleux eh bien nous serions obligés
de mettre plus parmi des établissements
qui longtemps bénéficié l'institut
d'études politiques de
saint-germain-en-laye 15 millions
d'euros pour soutenir et jeanne écoles
nées en 2014
ils vont servir à rénover des bâtiments
magnifiques qui relèvent vraiment du
patrimoine architectural mais qui sont
pour certains ils utilisable car
beaucoup trop désuet c'est un
partenariat qui se renforcent qui se
tissent qui a commencé par le bâti et
puis qui est devenu beaucoup plus fort
et qui voilà qui est important pour pour
tous les quatre projets restants
concernent l'iut de nantes mais aussi le
développement des pôles médicaux et
scientifiques à guyancourt et au bureau
portée notamment par l'université
versailles saint quentin
la première édition du festival
pulsations devait avoir lieu en 2020
elle a été repoussée à cause de la
pandémie
en attendant la tenue de l'événement
prévu désormais pour 2023 l'association
organisatrice anima sauce a souhaité
mettre en place des temps de rencontre
avec les partenaires
objectif maintenir le lien jusqu'au
festival le premier rendez vous a eu
lieu hier dimanche à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
justin brasey autant peau c'est le
premier club des partenaires organisé
par l'association anima sauce dans le
cadre du festival pulsations un
événement artistique et musical à venir
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
la rencontre entre les partenaires et
l'association a pris place à lille de
loisirs dimanche 13 juin au programme
échange présentation du lieu du festival
ou encore concerts objectif fédérer une
communauté et maintenir le lien jusqu'au
festival
l'idée là c'était d'avoir un événement
qu'ils soient récurrents dont d'avoir au
moins trois rendez-vous dans l'année
avec tous les partenaires soient des
partenaires qu'on a déjà contacté soit
des gens qu'on va rencontrer pour créer
une communauté autour du festival que
c'est une communauté avec des
institutionnels des associatifs des
individuels du territoire de 50 ans
la première édition du festival
pulsations est prévue à l'horizon 2023
partenaires du projet et c'est l'espace
événementiel de ligne de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines qui
accueillera l'événement est donc c'est
un superbe espace de 4 hectares plein
air clôturé avec des sanitaires des
branchements haïti et rick un terrain de
sport de plage et s'est parfaitement
adapté à l'accueil d'un festival de ce
type il y aura une partie et d'accueil
du public sous la partie du dôme et
ensuite tout le festival se fera à
l'extérieur donc autour du bassin avec
tes foutraque avec de la restauration de
la boisson pouvoir retrouver un village
artistique et solidaire avec des
ateliers participatifs collaboratif avec
une ou deux scènes musicales avec une
programmation d'artistes professionnels
d'artistes émergents du territoire et
puis aussi du spectacle vivant
au total une cinquantaine de personnes
étaient présentes pour cette première
rencontre
un prochain club des partenaires
pourrait se tenir au mois d'octobre
d'autres performances artistiques auront
lieu sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines pour faire patienter
jusqu'au festival et 2 information sport
avant de refermer ce journal d'abord une
versaillaise à l'honneur
aurélie tours 37 ans a été l'arbitré de
chaise de la finale hommes de roland
garros depuis 2010 9 elle officiait sur
des matchs du circuit atp
ouais s'est fait une place une finale
remportée par le numéro un mondial novak
djokovic contre stephano titi passes en
cinq sets 6-7 2-6 6-3 6-2 6-4 et dix
neuvième tournoi du grand chelem pour le
serbe qui s'impose pour la deuxième fois
de sa carrière sur la terre battue
parisienne
et en football j - avant l'entrée de
l'équipe de france à l'euro 2000 20
matches face à l'allemagne et les bleus
ont quitté leur centre d'entraînement de
clairefontaine dans les yvelines pour
rejoindre la base aérienne de vélizy
villacoublay et de live se sont envolés
pour l'allemagne direction munich
la rencontre entre les deux derniers
champions du monde est programmée ce
mardi à 21h c'est à l'allianz arena de
munich
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]